more violence in the occupied West Bank
Town of hawara Israeli settlers stormed
the Palestinian town on Monday night
apparently celebrating a Jewish holiday
young and old were targeted
indiscriminately this Palestinian family
had been out shopping when they came
under attack they needed hospital
treatment for their injuries after being
hit by Stones
we were just leaving the supermarket and
I was about to start a car when they
start throwing stones and I then
realized it was the settlers they hit me
on the head and then they sprayed gas in
the car look at my young daughter she's
two years old she was barely able to
open her eyes finally she managed after
almost two hours my father was also hit
by Stones there were bullies fired at
the vehicle too I honestly can't recall
how I managed to start the car and drive
off to save my family
[Music]
later in the evening Israeli soldiers
were filmed dancing with settlers the
Israeli Army has said it will open an
investigation
uwara is one of several Palestinian
towns surrounded by illegal Israeli
settlements with a large military base
nearby
Israeli settlers have carried out at
least 300 attacks in the occupied West
Bank in recent weeks
those attacks came after a Palestinian
gunman opened fire on an Israeli vehicle
driving through the town killing two
brothers
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has called on Settlers not to
take the law into their own hands but
Palestinians say that law only protects
Israelis and there is no accountability
for settler attacks Victoria Gayton B Al
Jazeera
well let's bring in Anita Ibrahim now
she joins us now from Ramallah Anita how
surprising is it to see these Israeli
soldiers celebrating with settlers after
these attacks against Palestinians
the fact that it's caught on camera kind
of shows what Palestinians have been
saying for years that if the Army
doesn't encourage the settler attacks in
the occupied West Bank it's usually
overlooks it because we've seen many
cases where in Palestinian Villages
nearby illegal Israeli settlers we see
Israeli settlers going into those
Villages attacking Palestinians often
armed these settlers have access to
weapons Palestinians are often unarmed
they're trying to defend their lands and
they're often surprised by the Israeli
Army basically turning a blind eye
towards these settlers that often attack
Palestinians but the fact that we've
seen that on camera has prompted the
Israeli Army to say it's launching an
investigation this is a term that we've
used and they've used over and over
again when it happens that such
violations take place on camera and are
shared on social media but for
Palestinians they will tell you that
they know this narrative for for years
and years we're talking about around
three settlers attacks each day on
average according to the UN figure this
is the highest number in two decades
Palestinians will tell you that the
settlers have been emboldened by the
lack of transparency lack of
accountability rather so they've been
launching attacks and the latest of
which we've seen in Hawaii that doesn't
seem to be ending as Palestinians were
telling us overnight the settlers were
coming in
in her water and the fact that they're
attacking them Palestinians feel that
they're helpless they're left alone
facing armed settlers who are often
enjoying the support of the Israeli Army
okay neither Abraham joining us there
from morale thanks very much Anita